peace be with you
welcome to the DS shell thank you for
tuning in our next guest was at the
convenience store going to get some food
that's what we do that's what we do we
eat we drink and where did we go to get
the food we go to the convenience store
so he's at the convenience store the
grocery store and guess what I mean you
would never fathom or imagine that the
story that you're in is about to get
robbed that's right sawed-off shotgun
but guess what he had a gun he had a gun
too so what happens next I mean you're
gonna have to tune in to this week's
show to find out now is it like the wild
wild west I mean we got the footage to
the surveillance cameras are on the
scene filming and my next guest he saved
the day find out what happened here on
this week's show and Mike Tyson now why
we mention needed celebrities because
most you people look up to him you
shouldn't it's a sad reality but Mike
Tyson our brother who's a Muslim too now
and we've invited him to be on the
program waiting to hear back Mike have
you people get in touch with our people
let's have you on the D show we're gonna
be talking about Mike Tyson also we got
some great advice for him luckily most
people wouldn't be brave enough to
mention Mike and give him some advice
but um do love the maker of mankind's on
on the side of those who speak the truth
and love the truth and luckily I know
some Gracie Brazilian Jujitsu so if Mike
throws a punch I can duck hunter take
him to the ground I would love out of
the love we love you Mike
we'll be talking about Mike Tyson to
here on the Dean show we'll be right
back for this exciting episode don't go
anywhere
this is the welcome jack to the Dean
show nadir peace be with you so I'm like
ooh
Adi was salam when i don't elaborate
gates how are you doing brother how many
love less privileged yeah I opened a
program we're gonna get into this story
very exciting you know I mean obviously
at that time I mean what exciting your
Bloods you're probably nervous how'd you
feel people the guy comes in you're
you're shopping when you get milk well
actually get us some vegetables that
store yeah healthy huh indeed and okay
so you're getting some vegetables what
are you shopping for what is interesting
because I believed that it was destined
to happen I should my wife initially win
of ourselves and I was on the phone
having a conversation my son started
crying and he was sitting with his
sibling so I say hey let me just going
inside so I went inside she was at the
cash register already well you want to
check out your wife's in the guest in
the story she's by herself so what
happens next so after I got in we were
in line I found her she was in line and
there was a couple and someone else
before us checking out and as I'm
standing there looking you know at the
cashier and talking on the phone I see a
security guard with his hands up and
he's walking I see a guy behind her with
a sawed-off shotgun in a bag and I'm I'm
thinking I can't believe it I'm like
this is not a robbery it was very did
that happened it's surreal you're just
like this could no no one could imagine
they're gonna find themselves in a
robbery sawed-off shotgun go off at any
time full grocery store about seven
o'clock at night so you got like so many
surveillance cameras we're gonna we're
gonna about to see some of this yes what
went down so what's going on to your
mind well first obviously get my wife
out the way I let her know she was
looking at me so she didn't see him she
didn't see anything
I saw it I backed away told her to move
out the way and hosted my firearm right
away
okay now people are like what are you
doing look we always look when I just
greeted just a peace be with you brother
we talk about Islam being a way of peace
we know that Islam is the way of light
that was sent down from the maker of
mankind submission to the will of God
and Jesus was a Muslim
you did its Lomb we talk about peace
peace peace and now you got a weapon and
somebody's like come on man phony
baloney these guys are carrying guns out
there what kind of people a piece are
they what are you doing with the guns
well the reality is we live in a violent
world okay and it takes people to check
other people so for example you look at
Moses I ladies and I'm and he fought we
look at ISA at least let me say I did
come to bring peace but I can't bring a
sword that's for Jesus in the Bible
exactly exactly improperly set the slum
for that the challenge is that you have
to have peace minded individuals who
want peace actually enforce action
unfortunately against those who don't
want it so you got a license to carry
yes Wisconsin just yes okay so this is a
legal firearm that you're carrying
absolutely your license you got a permit
everything registered and you have it
it's concealed and now guys got a
sawed-off shotgun right what does that
look like was it feel like well he had
it halfway hanging out of his miss
Jackie so most of it was concealed in
his Jackie and it was hanging out but
that's light now that's life or death
right now indeed because that shot out
shotgun goes off people if somebody's
dying right and he's waving at everybody
still waving at me wait he's doing like
this she's waving it is he saying
goodbye what's he saying we can't repeat
the word exactly
besides the profanities give him up not
you know not money nobody move give you
the money I want all of it putting out
the cashier who is crying hysterically
had it point at her head the whole time
well he's I'll kill you give me the
money yeah yeah he'll kill everybody you
know I put my hand up my left arm oh if
I put my body side to him because I have
a firearm all right am i right let you
know my right side and it was really
really intense because you don't believe
some like that it's about that okay walk
us through it now okay so let's do
what's going on good stuff well after I
saw the gentleman the guy come in to
fill up come in armed robber come in you
know it's one thing to call him a
gentleman I'm a wife out the way yeah so
he's walking and you can see him walking
in here in a surveillance camera right
right so got my wife out the way I
backed I wanted to put something between
myself and he's got the ID he's got the
hoodie on you see him he's walking in
like real sneaky
yeah hopped over nobody really saw him
now he's got the gun look it's just area
yes and these are the camera are
different clips from different angles so
that you can see what's going on who's
this lady in the in the in the green
right that's the cashier
broke up she's I mean you could she was
the same tariff she was this there but
she started crying she's putting the
money now what's that she's putting the
money in the back out putting the money
in a bag he wants all of it you can see
me in the top corner just positioning
myself between him and a pole now the
challenge is there was a guy who just
moved right there in the red the red
arrow died right the guy who moved and
right the guy who moved yeah he was
actually in the line of fire okay so I
would didn't want to shoot and put him
at risk yeah okay he went through
classes to learn how to use a firearm is
that right yes yes it's required in the
state of Wisconsin okay she had to
complete a course yes
oh it's for our training and the
challenge with this situation is there
was a guy that was on the back wall okay
so with him being on the back wall if I
open fire while he was still threatening
her with that gun it's possible he could
have gotten shot for me okay I want to
make sure obviously no no innocent
bystanders were shot so he saw me how
did he not he saw me we made eye contact
and I kind of nodded as we made eye
contact I said they're like that and he
moved out the way that's when I was able
to actually engage the challenge is I
was not properly prepared and what I
mean is I did not have a round in the
chamber
mmm all right cuz normally at home I
don't keep one there so that was one of
the scariest moments and longest
milliseconds of my life cuz how long
does it actually take do you need don't
you hear the sound when it goes into
check you can hear it I mean it only
takes a second or two but that I already
pointed so I had given the guy the
opportunity to see me because he still
was threatening to cash he had a gun
point your head while I had pointed at
him and pulled the trigger and nothing
happened oh but I had to engage rack
around and then I was able to let off a
couple rounds and hit him twice actually
once through the leg and the other was
graze on the forehead so he was shot and
he was they went to the hospital his
getaway drivers waiting for him they
caught him at the hospital shortly
thereafter so this is a moment of life
and death now it's like what have you
prepared I mean we never know when
somebody can pull out a gun you walk it
to your car you're walking with your
family whatever the cage is minding your
own business and that's it or are you
walking across the street and the car
hits you you know someone holds you up
like what happened here a very sad
situation but you got
Muslim you're Muslim and and this get
national coverage because the Muslim
will blow smoke the wrong way or you
know coughed the wrong way or and they'd
be like oh okay this guy sat with
somebody who knows somebody and he's a
Muslim and now national coverage and we
know that Islam has nothing to do if you
don't you know all these horrific crazy
things that are going out there but now
did this get press you know big time
press local press only it was there was
local press but this is you say that
when you talk about the most people get
national press from throwing a
firecracker on the wrong side of street
because there's just recently a mass
shooting in the Navy Yard yeah where the
guy just caught a shooter after killing
maybe a dozen people and because he's a
Buddhist he's caught a shootable we know
it had been a terrorist attack they had
to be Muslim unfortunately but no it was
it was a pretty hush situation but it
was the first time anyone had that had a
license as she stopped a crime in the
state of Wisconsin since that law has
been in effect that is so sad that this
this individual crazy individual killed
like in that Navy Yard how many 12
people yeah it was 12 13 people and yeah
and he was a Buddhist but Buddhism
doesn't come up or he used to be a
Christian he used to like to talk about
religion but now they're trying to
evaluate his head like what was going on
in his head he's mental but nothing
about terrorism or anything right and
more people were killed four times as
many people killed then in the Boston
bombing situation yeah we take a break
we'll be right back with more here on
the D show don't forget we've been
talking Mike Tyson we got some things
your friend knows a friend or your
figurative st. barbara's they go to the
same barber shop because we got some we
want to talk to Mike will be here with
Anadyr back to talk to you some more on
the detailed right back I'm so tired
when I read through the Old Testament
the New Testament it didn't make any
sense
feels like a walk a thousand miles when
I looked into the eastern faiths such as
our Hinduism and Buddhism and Taoism
about not uninspired done yeah got me on
money I agree with a lot of the
principles and ideas the same
Christianity and Judaism but they just
didn't strike a chord they didn't make
sense of but thankfully you've got Islam
oh and as a result of such I was not a
fan of religion is not a fan of
organized religion and I took a very
atheist approach towards belief and it
gets me through the trying times oh I
could leave work go have a bottle of
vodka some pack of cigarettes have a
double bacon and double cheese sandwich
and go to sleep drunk and happy he'd
come to work the next day and I was
miserable and when I read the noble goat
on Oh
what do you think about Christ what do
you think about God who is Allah who is
Muhammad it tells me what's the truth
and give me the proof was there some
little bit of intelligence and a little
bit of Investigation you can see that
this time set the boogeyman that has
been laid out my yellow lie is the one
the one the one one the one I didn't
believe in organized religion at all
to read the Quran I thought to myself
here's another book I can put on the
shelf of fictitious make-believe the
hobo the Lula took me three nights to
read the Quran and when I was done
reading it I remember thinking when it
was the first and to the state the only
religious book I've ever read that makes
sense
from beginning to end it doesn't
contradict itself it's an instruction we
living my life back here on the Dean
show and sad situation you know we don't
we don't want harm to come to anybody be
it you know a non Muslim Muslim
potential Muslim not yet most whoever's
out there I mean Islam is a peaceful way
of life and if people were living this
way of life you know even if if people
were just you know just had purpose and
this what this programs wheel about if
they knew their purpose in life when
people live for pleasing their creator
for living for a higher purpose you you
usually don't see people out there you
know trying to murder other people
bringing harm to other people is that
right yeah absolutely
is one of the things I've noticed is
that people who live with purpose have a
passion for life and not only their life
but others as well
yeah might we mentioned Mike Tyson so
you know you do follow boxing will you
Mike type most people know Mike Tyson
for boxing knocking everybody out when I
was a little kid absolutely I remember
playing Mike Tyson's punch-out did you
beat him at least I might know I did
yeah I got close but not yeah well just
like Mike Tyson he actually he went to
he went to Omaha was at Hodge and he
hooked up with a lot of our brothers
down there brother sedan Shadid Muhammad
Herrera dr. Brown who had on the program
they talked to him wonderful brother he
talked about you know that he's never
felt this kind of peace right
never did you also because you used to
be a Christian you accepted Islam can
you relate have you been to hajj also
yes can you relate to this piece that
Mike was talking about when it went when
you when you accept purpose what why
you've been created from the maker of
mankind
absolutely just to try to summarize my
story briefly as um I was raised
Christian Lutheran
in Christian private school from
kindergarten all the way to tenth grade
and I had a lot of questions that
weren't answered for me and as a
teenager and become rebellious at the
time I knew that my lifestyle was not
okay what I was doing would be okay as
long as you believe in are baptized or
you take communion and I said you know
this doesn't really make sense so what I
did is I just disowned or organized
religion or what people call it
organized religion uh so you know
Judaism somebody try to introduce me to
Islam when I first heard about it he
wasn't practicing number one but I knew
muscles were disciplined so I said I'm
gonna give up my women my weed or my
baby back ribs
that was my weed or my baby back yes I'm
not giving that up yeah so I didn't want
to hear it from him
but I still was soul searching because I
was in that religious environment I
believe there was a guy so I disowned
all things or organized religion and
said you know there's a Supreme Being
and long story just a tad longer is I
got just in trouble and a guy sent me a
book he said know it read this book and
the book dealt with the roots of Judaism
Islam and Christianity and as I've
looked in in the different roots in and
when it came to sort of Elliot class who
Allah a lot of some it'll emulate what
I'm you let when I'm yeah cool cool one
I you've memorized the original Arabic
you're not Arab but you're you're you're
you have like the Quran is in in in
preserve in the original language you
just recited indeed and that's one of
the that's one of the blessings and
mercies and things that is so attractive
you'll have to depend on a translation
of a translation of a translation I mean
you lose the original source so what
define what you just said
so who Allah who say he I lost one God
is one God the maker of mankind exactly
Allah who some met lost self-sufficient
it doesn't need food or drink he doesn't
need to rest on the seventh day okay I
really had a problem with that even
before I knew anything about Islam God
resting sounds like a weak God yeah um
yeah lid well I'm you let he begets not
he doesn't have any children nor was he
a child or born of anything or anyone
well I'm yeah cool ah Hoku for one I had
and there is nothing co-equal or
comparable to him at all nobody nothing
Jesus nobody nobody is comparable to the
crater nothing yeah and that right there
was in its essence what I believed
naturally and when I saw that chapter I
was like this is my religious what I
believed
simple it's very simple easy to
understand and you cannot get it
confused with other stuff and so on so
that's when I decided you know I'm gonna
be a Muslim now if we know that Jesus
was a Muslim Abraham Moses people kind
of like it's shark what do you mean
because simply a Muslim is one who
follows the will of God follows the will
of God that's it when you look at the
declaration in Islam or the Shahada lion
Allah there's nothing where the worship
set the law and we look at the first of
10 commandments that I was raised up
with he says you should have no other
God with me and when you look at it said
you should have no other it means that
negate it just like they show how to
sing laughs no nothing worthy of worship
except Allah no other god but me you
didn't believe in Trinity and all the
stuff that gets brought on and thrown in
and when you study the Bible you
actually recognize you just never said
I'm God never said I'm the Son of God or
worship me yeah to the country said my
father your father my God your God my
lord your Lord so the Bible led me to
Islam do you have a problem some people
they say okay we don't believe Jesus is
God but they say he's the son of God so
did you struggle with this because many
Christians our brothers in humanity who
we want the best for and everyone's a
potential Muslim they have the potential
to to do God's will and this is what
Islam means to submit to the will of God
not your desires but people struggle
with this son of God son I've got to
keep getting programs son of God why do
you have a problem with this personally
I did not my family my relatives still
do a matter of fact I need to make a
distinction there's a huge difference
between family and relatives
okay relatives you have a genetic pool
you share that with mother father
cousins aunts uncles and so on but
family there's a lot to other tales in
the map we need an equal they believe
it's nothing to set brothers so you're
my brother you're my family though we're
not related as a relative so when I made
that distinction the pain that came from
our family persecuted me our ridiculing
and and disrespecting Islam changed
because now I know where my family is
and how I'm bonded as opposed to my
relatives and I hope and want and dude
our two relatives to become part of the
family but as Allah lets us know we
can't necessarily guide those whom we
love he's in control the Creator that
heavens and earth so this son of God now
you know because if you read the Bible
you know everyone who followed the
commandments of God someone who was
pious righteous this was a son of God
according to the Bible's laying right
right in courting exactly according to
when it comes to looking at
Hebrew language and Greek scripture none
of them were taken as a deity none of us
so the way it's interpreting looked at
us today when someone says son of God or
children of God the same fashion when
someone says how much child of God
they're not saying their son or daughter
of God meaning their deity but they try
to put that title on Jesus which he
never called never he called himself
son of man that's like a metaphorical
now you can say indeed yeah and it
always has been it's not literal okay so
we get that other way that now you
believe that Jesus was a mighty
messenger just like Abraham Moses Noah
and all the other messages of the gods
sent and they came with the same message
worship the maker of mankind the creator
and not the creation that makes sense
it's simple simplicity simple pure
monotheism exactly yeah okay so moving
along now you mentioned we have the for
anyone wants to read you know study open
their mind their horizons the Quran
verbatim word of God does it have any
deficiencies in it defects if it did I
would have to disown it because we have
to give it the acid test that was the
challenge for me when I was studying
when I first read the translation of
corn I couldn't understand I'm like this
is in what we call an English first
person so it's speaking directly to me
and you can literally just open the
Quran up at any page and it will speak
to you and this is directly from Allah
to Allah so when I look at these
different things and I go back to what I
studied in the Bible where it goes and
Deuteronomy they prophesied about this
prophet that would be like Moses for
example who has nothing other than
Mohammed or they said to us none then it
made sense where it talks about he will
be speaking in a different tongue and so
on and so forth and under it smile the
firstborn son of Prophet Ibraheem yes
though we were taught Isaac was you know
so it just really solidified that is the
truth yes and if there's any air as I
have to disowned I can't base my
hereafter where I'm going to be longer
than I'm alive on some falsehood we want
to also help you know our brothers in
humanity now that have taken let's say
the Bible they take into these guys I
want to give them an example of what we
mean by deficiency or defect because you
said look if there's one defect
deficiency alteration of subtraction
addition is not from the crater
period what okay so look look there's a
man who are out there who he owned a m6
they said that this owner was the Hulk
over defect smashes his own car why
because this car you kept taking it back
and people are watching the video
right now because it has so many defects
and rillette and and recalls and look
what he's doing in the air look because
this car has defects man this is a
material thing look at this guy he's
smashing this car that's still worth I
mean a hundreds I don't know it's a
$80,000 so many hundred thousand euro
something like that but look they're
both smashing it they're making a
statement that has defects for us it's
no good but when you when you know we
make a comparison to our salvation we
can't follow a book that has been
changed been alters Bible scholars tell
us this yeah well it's anybody can see
if you go into the book of Revelation
you actually go to the last verse it
tells you if anybody adds or subtracts
from this the punishment of God is upon
them then you ask the Catholics who have
73 books in their Bible and the
Protestants which the losers fall under
who has 66 yeah so they argue amongst
each other what is actually part of the
book what's not and that's their
challenge and not ours with the final
book and that's why God sent the last
and final Testament indeed revelation of
the Quran preserve temper free temper
and we have it till the end of time
that's it and that's what you just
mentioned that's only the beginning I
mean if you look at how many other
version has been changed you know then
they say in the 1952 Revised Standard
Version too great that the the King
James Version has grave defects exactly
so no I got defects you wouldn't take it
what about the book now that's supposed
to be from God can't have patients here
after all
oh you can't be no no no one crater one
maker of mankind worship him alone and
we write back we still got to mention we
got to talk about Mike Tyson Mike Tyson
here we're gonna be talking about him on
the D shall we right back tune in Mike
please no going nowhere we got some
great advice to give you here on the
Dean show if you have a Facebook guys I
never ask a man to help I ask a lot
Kevin Facebook
make sure you like our statuses and
think about deaths was--they announcer
oh you never know that one person that
you shared one of our videos to and when
no one's looking you sneak and gives the
[ __ ] you never know that person might
teens and end up becoming Lissa and then
you can reap the rewards of everything
that person have learned has learned
from your share rush to work but you
late for salon a Muslim never brags what
does action say a lot like us like
Twitter and models on Twitter and one
last thing you want a piece of the
profit but not piece for the prophecy
that money is your Lords and you worship
the logic golf subscribe if you have
less youtube subscribe though the tab or
put on you learn words to the song
subscribe right now Pitman ties buy a
song link watching for Shaitaan you
watch the weight you put all good I'll
do it cut my head on the ground and my
knees on the floor and the devil my
everybody telling me to trade it for the
world right now say tomorrow do it now
Islam is the truth back here on the Deen
show and I'm didn't know that you got
out of that that robbery safe sound and
you save some lives potentially some
people could have been killed
did the mayor come down to the governor
did you get a call from Obama and they
give you a reward award no unfortunately
I didn't come out the closet as a
homeless sexy or to get a call from
Obama this is I'm not homosexual
nor did I get anything from the city or
Ottoman like they've given other people
of other faiths yeah
so hopefully look Obama tuning in or
some other governor or some politician
they watch the D choice amen look this
guy saved some lives you know we get
press coverage if somebody throws a
firecracker at the wrong ways Muslim and
it's all over the media we know it's not
doesn't have nothing to do with
terrorizing people and you know all
these things that been attributed to it
to it but now someone did some Muslim
did some good you know and you know I
did it you know in self-defense so the
recognition is Amy it's unnecessary and
we know that when it's your time to go
it's your time to go for example my
brother who law he passed me was 16
everybody took a shot at 14 yeah to the
dismay and really hatred of my mother
but he died defending his life in the
case of
an identity here you know so even in
this situation of defending myself it
was if it was my time to go how are we
going yeah so we must be cognizant of
that at anytime you know the Angel of
Death
he has our date mmm we're so we're
walking calendars some kind of love so
let's let's switch I want to take the
people you're gonna listen to a clip
right now a clip on Mike Tyson and then
we're gonna let's listen to this clip
and I'm negative and I'm dark and I want
to do bad stuff I want my I want to hang
out Mike this neighborhood alone that's
dangerous hang on this neighborhood
alone I hear right it wants to kill
everything to kill me to something I
hate myself I'm trying to kill myself
right you know I want to change my line
I want to live a different life now I
don't wanna live I wanna live my sober
life I don't want to die I'm on the
verge of dying because I'm a vicious
alcoholic and I've been I've been um Wow
I've been God there's some interesting
stuff with a huh
I've been on I haven't drink up took
drugs in six days and for me that's a
miracle I've been lying to everybody
else I think I was sober but I'm not
this is my sixth day I'm never gonna use
again gonna dear that was Mike Tyson and
he's he's Muslim we know that he's going
through some pain right now you can see
he's he talked about alcohol and
substance abuse and not wanting to die
what are your comics when you see this
well I'm done Darwin a lot of different
prisoners and one of the thing one of
things I find is that in the prisons
without all of these distractions but
that the outside has that people can
practice their Islam better so if Mike
will go if we can get him to go back to
a place in his mind when he was locked
up in a prison that distracted him from
all these other outside things because
we have to remember as Muslims this
earth is a prison for the believers but
it's a paradise for the unbelievers
dunya City no movement or genital care
indeed yeah so with that being said
you're just in a bigger prison with a
lot more things around you we know that
the way to Jahannam to where the
Hellfire is littered with all this good
good-looking stuff all these desires and
all these things where the path to
paradise is not an easy one so if we can
help him recall what he thought and what
he
thinking in the state he was in when he
was locked up when he was practicing
Islam when he was seeking the the mercy
and drynke from the stream of Eman and
feeling good and came out powerful and
making that change as opposed to where
he is now and getting alone and all of
us have a jinn that that tempts us and
allowing these other things to distract
him I mean he's had dealt with the death
of a child and a lot of things none of
us would want in our own lives but this
is a test for my last panel - Allen I
thought - I was all merciful yeah so
recognize that we even though he's been
released from the physical prison they
be still in a prison but Allah - Allah
is the one who gives us this freedom and
we again are headed on our way to death
yeah which is the awesome a reminder
here's another clip I'm gonna show you
another clip from one of the greatest
athletes boxers of all time Muhammad Ali
look what he says well they're not gonna
do the next 16 years what's the best
thing I can do get ready to meet God
owning a real estate going in business
teaching boxes that won't get me to
heaven well this glass came making
itself if I told you those clothes you
have them wove themselves nobody created
them those clothes made themselves you
and believe it but if your if your
clothes didn't make itself if that glass
couldn't make yourself if this building
didn't make yourself then how does the
moon get out there how do the stars and
Jupiter Neptune and Mars and the Sun had
in nature how did all this come here
didn't know why is something planning to
make it so we don't stay here we're just
trustees we don't own nothing even your
children are not yours if you think I'm
lying your wife is not yours you die and
come back a year later and go slip in
your bedroom and see if your wife is
bounced L say you don't own your wife
you know I divorce my wife you may read
about it and my four children they call
another man daddy now they don't see me
no more you don't own your children you
know and your family so what am I saying
the most important thing about life is
what's going to happen when you die are
you gonna go to heaven or hell and
that's eternity
how long is eternity let's imagine now
we wanted to contrast you see Muhammad
who's in a position also during his
career who's inviting people to purpose
reminding people when he was asked he
says look you know the best thing to
prepare for is for the day of judgement
for meeting your Creator and he's taking
that platform and he's inviting people
to the purpose of life helping to change
people's lives for a positive that will
be on a scale of good deeds isn't it
indeed but if you take this platform
that graters given you and you're
talking about you know many of the evil
things you've done for negating and all
the things that now we don't want to
think about we changed now we change you
might have been the worst like Malcolm X
and right you've seen his movie he gave
it up and he submitted to the will of
God how about Mike now how could we give
advice to loving advice because we love
our brother you know to take that
platform and use it for the crater rush
a time one of the great things when you
look at Muhammad Ali he's looking at
utilizing his influence to do dollar and
one of the benefits is those who become
Muslim you get the benefit of their
rewards when they do good deeds and if
they do bad deeds you don't get any of
the bad deeds
now with that it's a choice mike has
tremendous influence but unfortunately
his Wranglers and people that he will
put himself around her surround himself
with don't have his best interests in
mind it's more of pimping and my older
seeing how much money they can get from
him so with that the reminder of the
prison that you're in and surrounding
yourself in good company that in and of
itself subhanAllah I can make some you
know highly glorified as a lock that can
make a huge difference in life but more
importantly when we talk about the scale
of good deeds notice that that it's not
the number of good deeds but it's the
weight of them so utilizing his
influence and actually returning to
where he was when he was studying and he
was drinking from that stream movie man
can be influential on people help them
become Muslim and that can continue
because we know that we get three things
that count after we're gone that's a
righteous child that prays for you key
word being righteous child that prays
for you that's what we know Sarah
outstanding Muslim parenting calm then
of course wealth that you spit that
continues to benefit people and
knowledge that you've left that
continues to benefit people and he has
the opportunity at least to work on two
of the three of these things and Allah
Allah knows best and will allow us to
have that success and want us to invite
him you know to join us as his brothers
yeah to do the same and that's the the
best field to be in
inviting people to the purpose of life
and that's how you can really be
successful because the Creator is
telling us that this life the life of
this world is only the enjoyment of
deception isn't it I mean the crater if
all of what we believe as those who
submitted to the will of God the
verbatim Word of God where the crater is
telling us the life of this world is
only a deceiving enjoyment truly the
life of this world is nothing but a
quick passing enjoyment and verily the
hereafter that is the home what will
remain forever paradise and avoiding the
Hellfire I mean any any last closing
comments and advice from Mike Tyson he's
watching right now possibly what would
you say to your brother I would suggest
that the brother returned to his book
shut everybody out we turn to return to
this Quran to his Lord that knows him
through and through and created him and
loves us with our defaults in your
defects and all and drink from the
stream of Taba and remember the person
who killed 99 people still got paradise
you know even though some people told
him he wouldn't get paradise there's no
hope for him there's always hope as long
as you're living but don't take this as
a joke because a lot - Allah is the
loving yes but lots others just yes and
he's the forgiving but he's not a punk
yeah you can't fool a lot to Allah you
know as in other religions they say you
know I'm gonna do this now last
forgiveness later we don't play those
games so return sincerely to Allah when
you have an issue
alcoholism you look at companion I think
it was a new iron been the armor who had
had an issue alcoholic but how they
dealt with him in a society or look at
how Malcolm stopped her look out when
the ayah came the final prohibition on
alcohol how the streets of Medina were
pouring with wine and then take yourself
back to Medina take yourself back to the
Kaaba in the shade of the Kaaba and
remember how this Deen continues to grow
and touch people and know that your
heart is not too hard for a loss final
dollar change repentance all repentance
make repentance change your life Lord
the creator of heaven serves the most
loving the most merciful
but don't test them you can end up in
the Hellfire - right
Wendy's play don't play naughty exactly
this is not a joke it's not a joke he's
a light it was later done so let's
good let's do much good now before we
meet our Creator where can people with
Mike not Mike he said I like what his
brothers say you know where to look us
up Mike if they want he wants contact
you or anybody where can they find you
whoa outstanding Muslim parents calm so
I was standing mr. parents comment any
Muslim parenting calm because we want to
save our children for running a jaqen
media the way we ran from J Elliott it's
not I forgot to give you something okay
okay so gift from us to you for parents
because you are outstanding
this is a book Muslims parenting on
purpose Volume one so you have to worry
about the trial and error method at all
times as well as a six CD set was
setting the foundation and high
standards for famine find a said Muslim
parenting calm I'll stand about this
thank you again peace be with you again
brother
I mean why aren't a lot of slough off my
mother and thank you for tuning in we
had a lot of stuff to talk about today
on the D show I hope some of that stuff
has gotten to resonate think about it
ponder I brother Mike Tyson if you're
tuning in it's just a signal aside from
the creator of the heavens and earth you
know you don't expect them to put up and
someone to put a big neon sign and what
you know the Prophet peace be upon them
to come to you knocking on your door
this is how the signs work so let's work
to please our Creator before we meet our
Creator because def is a reality and
when it comes is too late it's finished
you can't go back and we know that
everyone who surrenders and submits to
the maker mankind the creator of mankind
the one that Jesus Moses Abraham they
all came with the same message didn't
come with different religions the
religion was always the same the way of
life is always the same submit to your
maker but when death comes they all warn
people about the Hellfire and paradise
but everyone who submits to the will of
God eventually if they die on pure
monotheism eventually as Muslims they'll
eventually end up in the paradise but
just like when you have a class acts
felony you know the the judge now
they'll give you probation or send you
to jail look you might end up spending
some time in the Hellfire may God
Almighty protect us from spending a
second in the Hellfire so we want to be
prepared for that moment of death when
it comes that now we've done as much
good we sacrifice we our life our prayer
everything was for the crater and when
we did a bad deed we did it we followed
up with a good deed and we raised our
hands and we said o the most merciful
the most
forgive us forgive us and then we we
live by those actions it wasn't just lip
service and we weren't fooled by this
but by the people around us who are
trying to just manipulate us and exploit
us and all of these things that really
at the end they don't matter but what
matters is the pleasure of our Creator
and eternity in paradise so let's be
good do good and Mike let's have you on
the program and let's continue to on our
Facebook you can go ahead and like us
there and follow us on Twitter we
started priceless blessings before we
cut out we had a we have a few people
you can also your countless blessings
hashtag priceless blessings at the Dean
show and couples that will share with
you that is my parents their love for me
from hasna Abdul Gani wrote my parents
love for me and patience from you this
is a priceless blessing another person
writes in the eyes that are able to
appreciate the beauty of Allah the
Creator is creation may God Almighty
bless us also right in with your at the
Deen show Twitter page hashtag priceless
blessings why so we can appreciate these
priceless blessings that if they were
taken away what would you do with the
money couldn't buy them so we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
yeah
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]